i hate intros the promise neverland
season one
episode one we kicked things off with
the introduction of the 11 year old emma
and her two friends rey and norman the
three of them are living in an
orphanage known as grace field house
there are 38 children in total living in
the orphanage and most of them seem to
get along well with one another the kids
are oversaw by a woman named isabella
and have to undergo tests to determine
their aptitude
emma ray and norman are a bit of
anomalies because they score perfectly
on their tests and are extremely smart
while playing we learn that the kids
will stay there until they find an
adoption family for them but they will
never stay there for longer than 12
years which all
sounds good but the problem is that the
kids that are adopted
are never heard from again one of the
younger children a six-year-old named
connie is adopted and prepares to leave
the orphanage
she is taken away by isabella and ends
up forgetting one of her favorite
stuffed animals so norman and
emma naturally rush to get it to her
they are shocked to find the little girl
dead in the back of a truck
a group of demons come out forcing emma
and norman to hide but they overhear
their conversation
the orphanage is actually a farm to
harvest children
and eat them isabella is revealed to be
in on this and
working with the demons they get out of
there undetected and decide that it's
probably a good time to start planning
their leave because they don't want to
die
in the last scene isabella finds the
stuffed animal that they were trying to
get to connie so she knows that somebody
was there ye
episode 2. norman deduces that the
reason they have to take the test
is because that's what decides what
order they're killed the lower your
scores the sooner you'll die and if you
manage to make it to 12 years old
they're gonna kill you anyways they
assume the logic behind this is that the
smarter you are
the better your brain will taste it's
gonna be another two months until the
next shipment at the earliest so they
have until then to devise a plan to get
all of the kids out of there
they venture out into the forest to
devise an escape route and end up
running into a thick concrete wall which
will prove to be their first challenge
another problem is that when one of the
children goes missing isabella looks at
some sort of tracking device to locate
the child
meaning that all of the children have
some sort of trackers implanted in their
bodies
in order to scale the wall they start
collecting tablecloths and hiding them
out in the forest and while doing this
rey approaches them saying that they've
been suspicious not knowing what else to
do they fill him
in on what they saw and their plans to
escape he is reluctant at first because
it's likely that there's some sort of
demon society outside of the gates and
keeping the young children alive will
prove to be difficult in that kind of
environment
it takes a little bit of convincing but
he eventually comes around to the idea
and agrees to help them when they get
back isabella announces that there is a
new infant joining their family named
carol
but it's not just her there's also
another adult helper named sister crony
who is likely working with the demons as
well
and brought in to keep things under
control yep so
three we get a small look at the
relationship between crony and isabella
where we learned that the two don't
really get along
isabella fills cronie in on the possible
breach but tells her not to do anything
and that she's gonna handle it
later on we see that crony is actually
wanting to take over isabella's position
as mother so she is biding her time
before she betrays her and sells her out
to the demons
jump on over to the kids who discover
that the new infant has a scar behind
her ear which is likely where the
tracking devices are located
in order to whip the other kids into
shape they play tag with them to get
their stamina up while them thinking
that it's just a game
crony joins in to low key flex on the
kids and tells them that if they can
survive for 20 minutes then they win
she ends up catching all of the kids
except norman and rey making them the
only winners
emma got caught too but to be fair she
was helping out the stragglers
in the last couple of scenes the kids
come to the horrible realization that
it's possible there is a mole amongst
the children
yep so four it's been two weeks since
connie was killed and everyone continues
their training by having the children
play tag in teams so that they're easier
to lead
in the escape while talking norman
informs emma and rey that the escape
days should be moved up because
isabella wouldn't see that coming this
kind of puts them on a bit of a time
crunch though because he wants to get
everybody ready in 10 days
knowing that they're gonna need more
team leaders for the escape the three of
them agreed to tell two other children
don
and gilda they formed them in on most of
it but norman decides against telling
them that connie was killed
and instead fabricates a story about
human trafficking he also lays a trap
for the child informant by telling them
the location of their ropes
we get a scene of the child informant
passing along this information to
isabella through a note
meanwhile gilda is being interrogated by
crony but luckily he doesn't give up any
information
on the next night norman springs his
trap and reveals that he believes it's
actually rey who's the informant that
has been spying on them
episode five ray comes clean about being
the spy working for isabella which he
had been doing for six
years in exchange for not being shipped
off he then claims to be a double agent
and the reason he's working with
isabella is to get information from her
and rewards that might help them in
their escape with that out of the way
rey agrees to continue helping with the
escape plans like normal but only on the
condition that norman gives up on the
idea of saving
everyone essentially what he's saying is
that they need to use some of the kids
as sacrifices because they're gonna be
too much of a hindrance
norman is conflicted but agrees to this
while also promising not to tell emma
the truth about getting all of the kids
out
the next day emma is filled in on rey
being the double agent and the three
continue their plans
after making some big brain plays emma
realized that there's a hidden room
inside of isabella's room likely used to
contacting whoever she was working for
they obviously want to know what's
inside the secret room but decide it's
probably too risky
don on the other hand was very close
with connie and is obsessed with finding
out what happened to her so he goes with
gilda to investigate the hidden room
episode 6 emma had discovered that some
of the books inside the library were
previously owned by william minerva
on the book plates were messages in
morris code presumably made by william
in an attempt to tell the kids the truth
dawn was apparently leveling his
pickpocket skills off camera and manages
to get a hold of the key to the secret
room
once inside they find the toys of kids
who were shipped off along with the
communication device that isabella uses
to talk with headquarters
they also came to the conclusion that
connie is likely no longer alive so
emma ray and norman had been lying to
them this prompts them to probe the
three
and they finally get the truth about
connie's death as well as the existence
of the demons
the next day emma lets norman in on a
new plan to get everybody out but we
don't hear what it is yet meanwhile dawn
manages to steal some chemicals to help
emma with her plan
jump on over to rey who meets with
isabella and learns that he will be the
next child to be shipped out while in
the forest the kids are approached by
crony who confronts them about
knowing the truth and in the last scene
suggests an alliance between herself
and the kids ye episode 7 crone wants to
work with the kids because if they
succeed in escaping then isabella will
be held responsible and crony will be
able to take over her job she also
reveals that she was once an
orphan just like them and even though
she managed to survive through all of
that she is now unable to leave the area
or a monitoring chip in her chest will
electrocute and kill her
well the three of them agreed to work
with her they also discuss amongst
themselves that they really can't trust
her
norman and emma go to croney's room that
night to ask a series of questions about
headquarters which is where the demons
run all of the plantations from
even after answering all of their
questions both sides are still
suspicious of one another withholding
information
over the rey who gets a camera from
isabella as per his request in exchange
for helping spy for her
later on the kids plan information for
cronie to discover about
isabella which she does and is overjoyed
about having some more leverage against
her the only problem is that in the last
scene isabella gives crony a note from
headquarters
explaining that she's being transferred
out episode 8. the letter from
headquarters also states that crone is
going to be appointed mother at another
plantation
as she's preparing to leave she meets
with the mysterious lady she answers to
that she refers to as grandma
kronay tries to sell out isabella to
grandma because she doesn't like her
and doesn't really want her plans to
work out unfortunately grandma
and isabella are working together
against her so grandma orders some
demons to kill cronie
we get some flashbacks of her life and a
touching scene where she's hoping that
the kids survive and
escape from the plantation but anyways
back over to the children who launched
their plan to investigate what's outside
the large wall
in response to this isabella finally
makes her move as well she goes on to
explain that she had taken care of crony
while also stating that the partnership
between her and rey is now
over she locks him in a room and uses
the tracking device to catch up with
norman and
emma who are at the wall don ends up
coming across right and lets him out of
the locked room while isabella catches
up with two with the wall
and asks them to stop she tries to make
a case for herself like ah you guys have
pretty good lives don't you think and
you should enjoy that until the end it's
kind of a shitty sales pitch so the two
of them refuse and emma grabs isabella
to create an opportunity for norman to
get over the wall
isabella isn't having any of that so she
breaks emma's leg
they get to talking and isabella reveals
that she really needs them because they
are the best quality meat suitable to be
eaten by
the one in the last scene we learned
that norman's day has been moved up and
he is to be shipped out
on the next day episode 9. determined
not to let norman die
rey gives him a makeshift taser and if
you're curious he got the parts from the
gifts that isabella had been giving him
in exchange for him spying for her the
plan is to have him use the taser to
disable his tracking device and then
pretend to escape
while really just hiding and waiting for
the real escape day in order to prevent
rey from being shipped out in his place
he decides to break a bone or become
sick because they can't ship damaged
goods to the one this makes norman agree
and we also learned the reason that rey
knew the truth about the demons is
because he wasn't affected by infantile
amnesia
now what the [ __ ] is that that means
that he can recall memories he had
as a baby which is why he knew the truth
about the outside world
jump ahead to the next day where norman
prepares to make his fake escape he
decides hey
since i'm out here i might as well try
out the actual escape plan so he ties a
rope to a tree
step two in the plan is scenario to run
up the [ __ ] wall
seems good step three in the plan is to
be on top of the wall without the rope
you initially came with and no coherent
way of getting down
we can just pretend that one didn't
happen i guess and he comes back
shocking everybody because he's supposed
to be hiding the reason he had to come
back was because outside of the wall is
a huge chasm surrounding the entire
plantation
as an extra precaution against the
children escaping
episode 10. norman also learned that the
house is inside a hexagonal property
that's completely surrounded by the
cliff
because of the gap around the plantation
there's only one way out and that's
through the gate
naturally the problem with that is it's
surrounded by demons and it also leads
to the demon headquarters
later that night norman reveals that he
never had any intention of faking his
escape he was just out there to get more
information
and was gonna come back regardless he
returns the tasered array and proceeds
to say goodbye to the rest of the house
in preparation for his departure
in one last moment of desperation emma
tries forcing norman to break his
tracker and flee but he stops her and
refuses before leaving to be shipped out
with isabella
once at the gate isabella informs norman
that he has to wait in a side room for
the demons to arrive
the last we see of him he seems to have
some sort of weird reaction to whatever
was in the side room back at the house
morel amongst everyone else seems to be
broken as
rey informs the others that he has given
up on escaping
jump ahead two months where in that time
the escape plans have been completely
stagnant
both emma and rey have given up on
living and are extremely depressed
the night before ray is going to be
shipped out he is approached by emma and
it's revealed that she still hasn't
given up on escaping and never
has episode 11 emma explains that since
isabella was watching her and rey they
had seemingly given up
but really don and gilda were still
progressing the plans
rey suggests that they set the plans in
motion that night and also the fun
little side note of him planning to kill
himself
he wants to die in a fire that will also
burn down the house causing a
distraction big enough for the others to
escape
as he goes to light himself on fire emma
saves him at the last moment and
convinces him not to kill himself
we finally get the big reveal of the
plan that emma had discussed with norman
which was actually convincing
all of the kids the truth ahead of time
two of the kids rush in to create a
decoy making it look like rey was caught
in the fire
because he's a bit of a delicacy and the
one has been craving that ass
isabella will be forced to try and save
him in the midst of all of the chaos
emma initiates the vincent van gogh
strat to get rid of the tracking and
escapes along with rey and the other
children into the forest
all of them reached the wall and prepare
to use their naruto while running skills
but then rey notices that the younger
ones aren't with them
meanwhile isabella is prevented from
calling headquarters because the keyhole
to the secret room had been filled
she does still manage to get the
transmitter before it's destroyed though
and in the last scene we see a little
boy come up and tug on her skirt
episode 12. the boy is phil and we see
flashbacks of him talking with emma
about the truth
they decided that the kids who are 4 and
under would have too much of a hard time
surviving outside of the wall
the kids agree to stay behind and wait
for emma to come back for them because
the kids aren't shipped out until
they're at least 6 years old this gives
emma
and the escapees 2 years to come back
before the kids are killed and rescue
them
they also have to keep in mind that this
is just one of the plantations and that
there are multiple connected to hq so
they're gonna have to save each one
isabella uses her transmitter to inform
headquarters that the kids are escaping
an alarm is sounded and all of the
demons are on high alert while the
children use makeshift rope to create
ziplines to cross the chasm luckily
isabella have learned the vertical
naruto run
also so she scales the wall and gets to
them just before
emma crosses the chasm we get flashbacks
of her growing up
and seeing people she cared about being
shipped off one by one
she was given the opportunity to escape
that fate by becoming a mother of one of
the estates
she began training to become a mother
and gave birth before becoming mother of
plantation 3.
while working there she realized that
rey is actually her son
because he was humming a song that she
used to while he was a baby he of course
never forgot the song because he doesn't
have infantile
amnesia and that's why it stuck back to
the present she takes down the rope and
returns to the other children to inform
them that they had successfully escaped
i'm gonna be doing the next season and
you can find that on the left side or
you can check out all the promised
neverland videos in the playlist on the
right side you can also find the links
in the description below and the only
thing i hate more than intros is outros